[Applaudissements]
bon ça je suis un peu comme le nem sur
le gâteau vous avez certainement
remarqué que j'ai un petit accent
alsacien
en fait je suis originaire de hong kong
et je voudrais ce soir partager avec
vous ma quête pour l' équilibre à la
fois les équilibres culturels et
identitaires donc un petit teaser voici
comment j'étais il ya 30 ans voilà donc
voyez vous un petit gros au milieu ces
mots à ces mois à 10 ans et je du
parcours ya pas mal de choses pour me
pour me trouver dans un premier temps
c'était c'était un décalage culturel
complet
je suis arrivé en alsace et non
seulement je ne comprenais pas le
français en plus le plus dur était de
comprendre vos codes vos valeurs
je savais pas pourquoi il fallait pas
parler trop fort alors que vous avez
l'habitude de vous moucher avec toutes
vos forces
je me disais que ce qui sort de ma
bouche des départs plus dégueulasse que
ceux qui sortaient de veau né et aussi
au niveau de mon estomac ge du jeu de me
réadapter vous avez cette salade de riz
qui vraiment dégueulasse
pour les asiatiques de riz ne se ment
jamais froid ou alors en fait c'est une
nourriture quand gare pour donner aux
cochons le lendemain voilà et aussi au
niveau des valeurs j'étais assez
perplexe je me dis que dans ce monde il
ya des gens généreux partout mais vous
êtes généreux d'une façon très
particulière
à hong kong par exemple on va aller
invité les voisins a dit d assez
aisément mais on va jamais descendre
dans la rue pour crier au nom des
tibétains en revanche chez vous c'est
très drôle on va se manifester
peut-être en posant un jour de rtt pour
une cause lointaine alors que vous êtes
incapable de retenir les prénoms de vos
voisins du palier dont je me suis dit
voilà on a on a vraiment plein de
repères complètement différent et voilà
je joue du jus du vous cherchez et aussi
me trouver là dedans est encore au
niveau de la langue c'était hyper
curieux parce que pour le petit garçon
que j'étais ou que je suis encore il
fallait toujours me positionner est-ce
que je suis travailleur aux
travailleuses
est-ce que je suis beau je suis belle ou
alors est-ce que je suis sympathique ou
sympathique à la je trouvais une
pirouette m'achever rester sympathique
tout le temps
ça va m'aider temps au lieu de chercher
dans les différences je m'accrochais
désespérément aux valeurs communes aux
valeurs universelles et un ca me sauver
chaque fois quand j'étais encore petit
garçon je voyais aucun problème en fait
c'est le monde extérieur qui me disait
qu'il y avait un souci avec imprimant un
jour une prof m'a envoyé au tableau pour
régler une équation
et puis une fois terminée je suis allé
simplement à ma place et tout d'un coup
elle a crié mon nom d'amal ces moments
en cantonais et je comprenais pas
pourquoi et toute la classe a commencé à
se moquer de moi et je comprenais pas du
tout du tout pourquoi je me suis ainsi
et au bout de cinq secondes 10 secondes
je me suis dit peut-être la professeure
à crier et que tout le monde a hurlé de
rire parce que en fait jeter un petit
garçon qui avait une démarche très
efféminé et là je compris je compris que
en fait pour le monde extérieur
il y avait un problème il y avait un
souci et heureusement cela ne m'a pas
empêché a gardé de très bons contacts
avec ma famille peut-être parce que déjà
mes parents étaient très ouverts
d'esprit et ils le sont toujours
et en fait même si j'avais 10 11 12 ans
je vis tu vu que c'était une façade une
facette de moi le fait d'être un petit
garçon efféminé
c'est juste une partie de moi et en
aucun cas j'allais laisser cet aspect
parasiter ma vie et me rendre malheureux
donc en famille ça lui allait plutôt
bien ça allait plutôt bien
et évidemment alors on me disait tout le
temps qu'il fallait pas choisir le rose
ni le bleu pastel tout ce qui est pastel
tout ce qui me plaisait c'était interdit
et mon grand père était très tolérant il
veut laisser jouer avec mes poupées et
c'était c'était plus à l'école avec un
homme
je me suis vite rendu compte que j'étais
pas un petit garçon comme les autres
j'étais pas du tout une petite vie non
plus en gt coin alors je cherchais je
cherchais un jour je pense que j'avais
environ 10 ans 9 ans 10 ans mon père est
revenu à la maison avec un un album
c'était beau jones je vis beau george
recommandé par mon père indirectement je
me suis dit ok pâturages
pourquoi pas et ça m'a ouvert les portes
je me suis dit en fait il ya mille
façons d'être un homme
il ya mille façons d'être une femme et
je n'allais pas forcément devoir me
conformer à une image conventionnel un
peu plus tard d'autres questions se sont
posées
je vu que en fait j'y viens
une médecine qui permet de changer de
sexe je me suis dit qu'est ce que c'est
que ça est ce que c'est la solution
miracle est ce que c'est ça ma voix et
en même temps très vite mon ego a pris
le dessus
faire une opération pour moi ce serait
de reconnaître une sorte d'erreur en moi
et je ne peux pas je ne veux pas dire
que la nature puisse produire une
créature erronées ou qui serait une
erreur maintenant je regarde un jardin
je vois toutes sortes de fleurs
toutes sortes couleurs toutes sortes de
formes et je le fais partie que de ce
jardin peut-être une plante un peu
bizarre mais ce n'est pas la peine de
couper cette plante est donc très vite
j'ai abandonné cette idée d'intervention
extérieure et je compte y uniquement sur
mon mental et petit à petit la plante a
poussé et sa poussée plus ou moins sous
une forme qui me convient qui reflète
qui je suis et je me suis rendu compte
aussi que on et rendrait les deux pieds
dans une époque de politiquement correct
où chacun doit avoir une étiquette et un
titre pour se défendre pour se protéger
ou pour se sentir fort dans une
communauté
quand je me suis dit c'est clair que je
ne suis pas un homme blanc catholique
c'est clair que je suis pas une femme
féconde et qu'est-ce que je suis alors
est-ce que je suis homosexuel
un jour une copine
dix ans plus âgé que moi m'a présenté
ses oncles qui sont des gens très
respectables homosexuels avec une bonne
situation et je me suis dit que tout ça
était absurde
ce n'est pas parce qu'on a je sais pas
ce n'est pas parce que on éprouve le
désir pour les personnes du même sexe au
où ce n'est pas parce que je suis passé
des papas se former les même robe que
tout d'un coup qu'on a qu'on partage les
mêmes valeurs
je voyais vraiment aucun sens à
m'associer à une quelconque communauté
et plus tard on m'a dit hein
voilà bah tu es travestis et je lui ai
dit est ce que tu m'as vu en costume
cravate
c'est encore pire et et plus tard j'ai
entendu toutes sortes de thèmes surtout
une fois lancé dans le milieu du
spectacle
il ya des journalistes qui semblent
connaître sans me poser la moindre
question mettait humoriste transgenres
ou alors comédienne transsexuelle et je
dis moi qui consomme 100 % bio pourquoi
il met trans qui a eu qui a bien pu
vérifier alors que c'est tellement
intime qui a eu la certitude de bon sexe
un jour je t'ai je découvert sommes
sûrement wikipedia quelqu'un qui a écrit
toute une histoire sur moi comment je
tenais quel genre d'opération chez eux
quel genre de traitement et tout était
faux et je dus me bagarrais en fait vous
allez voir si vous êtes célèbre un jour
vous allez avoir une page wikipédia et
il est impossible de mettre la main
dessus
en fait votre identité ne vous
appartient plus et je me suis rendu
compte que finalement qui on est ce
n'est pas nous qui le juge on sait le
monde extérieur qui met une étiquette à
ce moment là je me suis dit autant
respecté cette perception de l'autre hui
si c'est elle qui détermine qui nous
sommes et j'ai commencé à avoir une
ouverture d'esprit
si la personne en face voit un homme et
m'appellent monsieur très bien et si la
personne en face
voir mon côté féminin et m'appelle
madame pourquoi pas ce serait tellement
fermé d'esprit de ma part d' exclure
cette possibilité d'être un homme ou
cette possibilité d'être une femme et je
refuse je refuse de reprendre ce
fermeture d'esprit qui m'a fait tant
souffrir
je refuse de me poser à nouveau
donc aujourd'hui je me dis voilà soyons
libres soyons libres dernièrement j'ai
entendu cette expression
le troisième sexe qui était censé être
une expression alternative pour me
réconforter
moi j'ai entendu ce qcm hermaphrodite au
parfum diane androgyne à ça ressemble un
peu à un médicament contre la diarrhée
mais mais bon ok troisième sexe je me
dis bon déjà c'est un espace confiné et
vous mettez en un troisième sexe et
jeudi mur on va où on va où vous est ce
que on peut pas simplement regarder la
personne qui est en face avec son
individualité son côté unique parce
qu'on est tous uniques et en souffrent
tous de l'étiquette qui ce qui se
reconnaît dans l'étiquette du bobo
parisien ou du cadre dynamique
légèrement dégarni ou de la ménagère de
moins de 50 ans qui regardent batterie
sébastien personnes personnes et
peut-être avec le travail que je fais
c'est à dire le travail sur scène je pu
relativiser je pu endosser d'autres
personnages aussi les applaudissements
évidemment ça flatte l'ego la famille
que j'ai eus qui est extrêmement aimante
et ouverte d'esprit ça m'a beaucoup
beaucoup aidé et et voilà du coup vous
je pense que je suis tout à fait
tolérante et ouverte à toutes sortes
étiquette parce que finalement pour moi
il n'y a aucune étiquette qui est
valable à part sa vraie personnalité
et pour finir je vous souhaite de
trouver un équilibre entre ce que
perçoit le monde extérieur de vous et
qui vous êtes réellement merci
[Applaudissements]